good morning Hank it's Tuesday quick
note we will be on tour this weekend in
Madison Wisconsin and Minneapolis
Minnesota hope to see lots of you there
links to tickets in the doobly-doo so a
little known fact about me is that I
nearly failed 11th grade English there
were several reasons for this for
starters my teacher and I had
fundamentally different belief systems
about class attendance his being that
students should attend class and mine
being yeah but also I just wasn't a
great reader I really struggled with
critical and abstract thinking and our
teacher was always trying to get us to
understand like metaphors and how
different narrative structures could
shape reading experiences and all that
stuff now these days I believe that when
we talk about metaphor and the like
we're mostly talking about how to use
language in ways that foster deep
understanding like if a writer tells you
that a character has anxiety you might
register that and move on but if a
writer can use figurative language to
put you inside that character's head you
can actually experience that anxiety you
can glimpse not just what it's like but
what it is
that's why metaphor exists not to
torture high school English students but
to make the dull bright and the old new
and the distant close anyway high school
me thought all of that was a bunch of BS
and that laying a live novel upon a
table and dissecting it was a form of
torture for all involved so that was
part of the problem but also I missed a
lot of class and never turned anything
in on time as my teacher wrote in my
report card that year John has reached a
juncture where he just can't mail it in
anymore so I tell this story for two
reasons first to point out how many
chances I had like if I hadn't had
extraordinary teachers who believed in
me and school systems that supported
those teachers I might never have
graduated from high school that alone
college but also because I received an
incomplete in 11th grade English in
order to pass the class I was required
to read two books over the summer and
write papers about them one was Twelfth
Night by Shakespeare the other was Toni
Morrison's first novel The Bluest Eye
we'd read Morrison's novel Song of
Solomon that year in English class and I
liked it or at least I liked the parts
that I read and so my teacher ordered me
to read The Bluest Eye which is about a
young black girl named piccola Breedlove
who was told by the social order that
she's ugly and who grows up horribly
mistreated by people who claim to love
her
it's a structurally innovative novel
that uses point of view with astonishing
brilliance but it's also accessible and
reading it absolutely wrecked me I still
remember the tears streaming down
my faces I finished that book the dense
fear of longing and sadness in my chest
I'd known of course that the world was
unjust but reading The Bluest Eye I felt
it and I wanted to write about that book
I wanted to write about how this
character had been traumatized not only
by individual people but also by a
racist and misogynistic social order and
while writing that paper I also began to
understand that what my teacher called
mailing it in was itself a privilege and
that I wasn't being cool or clever by
skipping class I was wasting
opportunities that many people are never
given later that summer I read
Morrison's novel beloved even though it
wasn't assigned for school and I reread
Song of Solomon all of it this time did
I understand all of the endless nuances
and resonances of those books of course
not but I loved them they challenged and
haunted me as they challenged and haunt
me still and they made me if not a good
reader at least an enthusiastic one Toni
Morrison died last week and it is hard
to imagine the world without her Clarion
voice but the books survive they go on
helping readers young and old see the
world more clearly in her Nobel Prize
lecture Morrison said language alone
protects us from the scariness of things
with no names
she gave language to so much and to so
many Hank I'll see you on Friday